le sénat qui examine en deuxième lecture
en nouvelle lecture ce projet de loi sur
le pass vaccinale j'ai plaisir
d'accueillir bruno retailleau au micro
bonjour bonjour si le sénat siègent à
nouveau aujourd'hui c'est de votre faute
dit la majorité présidentielle c'est
vrai c'est votre faute non attendez la
belle affaire d'un tweet qui arrive
quelques minutes plus tôt qu on
comparerait presque dont ceux qui
connaissent l'histoire de france à la
dépêche dems qui avait provoqué la
guerre de 1870 entre l'allemagne et la
france franchement la belle affaire on a
dit que c'était un tweet qui était
attentatoire aux institutions fige un
coup d'état non c'est totalement
disproportionné
parce qu'on était en train de trouver un
accord un accord je crois d'ailleurs
avait été trouvé et c'est
disproportionné parce qu'il ya un tweet
d'un côté un peu rapide bien sûr
rappelez vous que vous connaissez et
puis et puis nous pondent malheur est
bon du tout du tout non et puis de
l'autre côté et puis de l'autre côté à
face de ce tweet est une urgence
sanitaire bon voilà donc je trouve que
c'est totalement 10,3 pour suite
d'autant plus que mon groupe au sénat
depuis le départ a voté le pass
sanitaire et que nous avions voté le
pass vaccinale et que les débats ici
tout le monde l'a dit d'ailleurs avait
été de haute tenue donc franchement je
pense que c'est un prétexte politique
politiciens et rien d'autre donc pas là
vous ne reconnaissez pas des noms en vue
d'une paix comme dégage une rapidité
mais mais totalement un débat totalement
disproportionnée évidemment les français
l'ont connu ont compris comme ça
personne n'a compris d'ailleurs 28 un
peu rapide est interrompue ce que les
coalitions liste effective à riscle
inédit sur le fond donc les députés ont
adopté un texte dans la nuit vous les
sénateurs vous examinez 7 en deuxième
lecture ce texte qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette nouvelle mouture du
texte quelles sont les lignes rouges ont
dit contrôles d'identité ont dit aman
nos entreprises pour vous c'est non
c'est ça non mais y est on va prendre
tout ce qui va dans le bon sens et on
veut encore une fois protéger les
français on pense que la vaccination ses
protecteurs c'est tout voilà les
chiffres le montrent point final il ya
des choses qui vont dans le bon sens qui
ont été reprises notamment pour les
moins de 16 ans désormais ce sera pas le
dax
parce vaccinale ce sera le pass vaccine
air bag ces pardons vaccinale que ce
soit pour les activités scolaires estrac
tu as l'air ou le loisir idem pour les
gens qui ont une première dose faut pas
leur tomber dessus faut leur laisser le
temps d'avoir un schéma vaccinal complet
donc il ya des choses qu'on va prendre
parce qu'ils sont positives ils vont
donc ça va dans notre sens en revanche
il ya deux points qui sont des lignes
rouges c'est vrai les contrôles
d'identité en france voilà ce sont les
officiers de police judiciaire un
conseiller un policier municipal ne peut
pas n'a pas droit de réaliser ce
contrôle l'a donc franchement demandé à
nos cafetiers restaurateurs de le faire
ils font déjà y contrôler le passé des
chats quand même bien et ensuite le
nouveau régime de sanctions
administratives pour nos entreprises
franchement ces amendes aux entreprises
qui ne respecteraient pas par exemple le
télétravail c'est ça oui mais regardez
il ya eu l'administration a fait des
contrôles ces contrôles ont révélé que
seulement
0,37 pour cent des entreprises avaient
été fautive et alors on va encore une
fois ça c'est bien français mettre un
dispositif de flicage toutes les
entreprises et demandé aux inspecteurs
de travail de déterminer l'organisation
interne de travail dans l'entreprise
savoir si tel poste et les travaillable
tel prost ne l'est pas et si on ne
respirait un peu et si on peut faire
confiance les entreprises elles ont
mille peines aujourd'hui on va pas leur
tomber dessus faisons leur confiance
elles agissent avec responsabilité et
les contrôles l'an demande et donc nous
je pense quoi on a déjà un régime bien
sûr de sanctions pénales et ça m
intéresse c'est ce que vous dites ça
suffit c'est le juge qui décide et pas
l'administration alors si le sénat ne
vendent pas conforme c'est-à-dire dans
les termes identiques à au texte adopté
par les députés hier soir
finalement vous travailler un peu pour
rien aujourd'hui c'est l'assemblée
nationale aura le dernier mot demain non
on travaille jamais pour rien vous savez
que dans le processus législatif à la il
ya un texte qui va de l'assemblée et au
sénat dont le modifie y aura dans le
texte final des modifications je viens
de le dire qu'ils devront beaucoup
possèdent à assas et comment dirais-je
le modèle de la coopération sous la vème
république une joute navette
parlementaire n a pas été un peu
parasité par l'élection présidentielle
quand même à 100 jours maintenant
d'élections non moi je n'en je crois pas
du tout attendez ce qui parasite
franchement les propos du président de
république qui avait eu des mots
terribles pour les personnes non
vaccinées je pense pas que c'est plus
apaisé le débat encore une fois ce débat
il existe moi je suis pour le pass
vaccinale fait tomber entourage temps
mes amis en a qui sont contre voilà et
c'est parfaitement normal que le débat
dans la société ils se reportent dans
nos assemblées et je dois dire que c'est
important parce que si nous on n'a pas
ce débat ici dans les assemblées il sera
où il sera dans la rue avec de la
violence donc voilà je pense que la
démocratie c'est pas toujours un
consensus et parfois indices en sus on
n'essaie pas à pas alors si parfois
laborieux d'améliorer les choses c'est
ce qu'on fait et on y travaille avec une
ligne on s'y tiendra voilà est loin de
toutes les autres perturbations
[Musique]